la vecchia sto buttando tutto il monitor
apex legend due vittorie tutte per voi
ho scelto un personaggio diverso ragazzi
perché voglio mi piacciono le sfide
ecco è l'unico modo per girare in fiera
per me sarebbe fare il cosplay di
bloodhound are we going se vogliamo
cambiare un po di porto zona in zona
calda proprio la zona calda ma come
aiuto a questo è successo ma dove state
andando che state andando sulla
obiettiva la gialla si serve perché è
perché mi sono staccato da solo come
premuto e a caso no ti giravi siete
partiti almeno mi sono lanciato insomma
mai allenata da ci sono sempre ho un
sacco di epiche e minimo una leggendaria
solo che bisogna trovare la leggendaria
questo il problema
ma perché tu vedi la zona calda si
chiama zona calda siviglia mini mappa è
cerchiata in blu
questa è la zona calda ce n'è sempre una
sola inizia a partita e la gente in
genere viene qua se è tipo i pinnacoli
di forma insomma ok però non lo cambio
di ceo cavoli
penso di aver trovato la leggendaria no
era una luce attaccata alla gente o
ragazzi gente d'altra parte la segnala
segnala bruciarli il tecnico è che la
natura viola andiamo andiamo andiamo
dove ci sarà un'azione la causa non la
causa di gara
colpito il beat of terra una terra buona
un corteo perché qua avevano segnalato
altri che avevano sentito che abbiamo
sparato e quindi saranno la e qualche
ragazzino mi sto qui non vi sto dando
supporto di nino è morto tutte e due
contro due io continuo a non vedere
nessuno di tutti quelli che state
facendo un po
vengo dal tuo lato lo renderebbe essere
lì mi sa dove che promettono in casa
siamo
no non vedo né sopra saprà vedo arm e
aspetta 35 secondi però va da me non è
creato giu
un'acqua dai metronotte entrambi loro
dire mila smokes di mettere la smetta di
mestre è nuovissimo leader perfetta
mentire mila small pietra dietro che va
dai caveau
ok vaia vaia mi sparano niente ma porco
demonio ma la doll velocemente un tele
porter tra un secondo se dovesse
riuscire a prenderlo ora ma lo si nota
che mi curo che se non muoio mai hanno
sparato dal nulla allora possono usare
il tele porter anche se il tuo pietro
che lo copre sì sì comunque possono
usare bloccato uno agli atom o ragazzi
non li vedo guarderà di morti morti
morti morti tutti i morti c'è ancora
gente quanto acqua quasi gente ci dente
ragazzi occhio tomtom one way down
ragazzo un po tutti i morti tranquilli
se rifugiate veli parte aggressivi e non
oa dove ricarica entra entra inter
aggressivo come vai morti tutti ma sappi
che buchetta quindi abbiamo fatto è
stato è stato veramente assurdo ok anche
perché fino adesso non avevo fatto nulla
regata ero io scusate non riuscite a
fare meglio a vederne neanche uno a fare
niente sentivo abbiamo recuperato fai
tutte le nostre abilità benissimo direi
bambini in situazione per fortuna
ragazzi possiamo passare dalla caverna
sembra che un pezzo sia in ser
guardando la mini mappa dovremmo
riuscirci la mostra fiero si può si può
guardare non ci credo bellissimo il
passaggino lo trovano pensa a loro poi
non si aspettano nessuno di qua trovate
un e dow siete con me l'altro si no
eccolo vedo 2 down ne manca uno che ha
un hp è dietro probabilmente la non so
dove forse sopra sopra non c'è nemmeno e
smoke uccidetelo c dietro lo scudo
leggendario si sta tirando su
stabilmente ok ok lo re tiramina smoke e
tiramisù pietra sempre la sbocco andrea
danti non vedo a chi sta per sparare li
e li sta facendo il giro ad agire a
sinistra prende tempo con voi ma amava
arrivo bangalore senza fiat la smoke
senza armatura si sta curando del pre la
svolta ai abbia sparato ha sparato non
sanno dove dal cielo al tetto ha detto
la porta che è ora quelli sul tetto vi
faccio un tp per andarci estate siamo
tranquilli scioccato grande bob
porca vacca è però le martellate le
porte propria fede dov'erano è uno era
il soggetto non so il nostro quale
mannaggia nola sulle montagne e quando
sono un paniere no io uno sulla montagna
l'altro dove la la la la la la
no non certo ok tg3 di fila le cose
fatte bene non scegliermi blood hound no
no
si no
è il primo gioco online dove mi chiamo
fuori genti bene bambù l'ho fatto perché
sappiamo che spaccherà e quindi mi
porteranno il nick name light
allora io ragazzi non so se ve l'ho
detto ma io non accetto sconfitto sono
qua per vincere dobbiamo perdere non
giochiamo
no no no no no no erano qua a lottare
sono spostati verso da sei sicuro e
sentire che sparano pensavo mi avessero
sentito questa utenti pia sono qua un
team quando partendo con un'altra
squadra da quella parte perdiamo quali
si dico a destra organizzarono un e da
un andato eva e vabbè maretta 3 contro 2
e sul prato amico mio questione
per un attimo il caso noemi e mi ha
voluto il mio meglio
ho ucciso mez sul real s e quello che
penso su rialzi sia lui lui e sul 6 6
cavalca le sberle che mi stanno tirando
occhio dice a gente come testimoniato da
un romeno lo vede dal traguardo in
affari 6
e poi poi quanto è uscito subito ok sì
sì è morto è morto robot robot scudo blu
venitemi e io vorrei notare però se in
questo gioco tranquillissima ok al
cecchino perfetto la coop variabile è
meno forte del cecchino 6 per i bambini
gioiosi man
sì sì al bari i 48 fare più all'anno che
si chiama angotti un paio viola ma
cambia solo la mirano 6 ambientale più
preciso aiuti consiglio 6 fare al posto
del dl 4 parti anche se le altre viola
se anche se l'unico viola da cecchino è
il 48 purple e viola ed e mi manca nel
pezzo davanti la cecchina il pezzo
dietro stoffa tutto alternato
chat raccolti e poi muore per voleva
tanto rivera che fa precedente ma anzi
mi ha sparato e maggior ha subito
colpito
levato tutto lo scudo ragazzo sempre ce
n'è uno la destra c'è un'altra qua sotto
guarda come preso bene vai sono con te
perché eccolo dietro di sociologia e gli
ho detto mi regala faccio un giro un
occhio faccio un altro team che
arrivando da dietro
si no dalla adesso dalla laddove talking
al nostro thing andò dietro sta attento
dietro di te sono at home tv the sun
ecco sono in forma e formule fermo
davanti a te ti morte la gente ancora
gente dove scherzando scherzando
abbiamo ultimato bella la catacomba solo
la ulti con con la smorfia solo che ho
voltato mi servirebbero degli scudi new
york schifo questo forse ne ha seguaci
sono contenta nord oggi vorrei
recuperare tutta la loro stessa non
uscendo bene da un nuovissimo non li
vedo in gara dunque dietro ecco ago
oltre solo 40 migranti secondo me sono
dentro la base missilistica è uno shock
gallo scelga leggendario che sarà solo
nell'erba angoli volete che provati
arrivare volevo e non bruciate capito 1
giu no non è vero ne giu no non orari 1
allora ok gioco adesso un aiuto un altro
da dietro che si cura quasi giu
senza amore alla così portati per
un'opportuna secolo si cercano pietro
per la vittoria dai e cioè dove è morto
eccolo frutta ecco ecco la cosa non so a
chi mai rubato 120 col basti fare una
rubata il resto il vostro dai è vera
vero ragazzi e dire regalano ai per
fatto 44 in oggi quattro game iv oggi in
crediti e vero sono quattro partite di
fila che vinco impossibile e tom non è
la quarta di fila per i ragazzi questa è
l'altra e due vittorie ops legend
passate anche lei calari dei miei
fagiani amici in descrizioni come senza
servire piaciuta sia un commento mi
piace ancora che cosa sentenziare il suo
stato che si chiede decidiamo cosa al
massimino scia
[Musica]